[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend spätestens seit dem sturm
aufs kapital ist klar dass dem
ehemaligen us-präsidenten trump vieles
zuzutrauen ist was man zuvor für einen
präsidenten undenkbar hielt ein
gewaltsamer putschversuch angefeuert vom
abgewählten amtsinhaber das ist auch im
rückblick immer noch ziemlich unfassbar
seine gegner halten aber auch noch
andere formen des hochverrats für
möglich zumindest fragen sie sich warum
trampel überhaupt vertrauliche
regierungsunterlagen aus dem weißen haus
mitnahmen us medien berichten heute dass
das fbi bei ihm nach geheimdokumenten zu
atomwaffen gesucht haben soll matti
wissen berichtet
einst plauderte donald trump in seinen
golf club mit dem damaligen japanischen
premier hinzu habe trotz anderer gäste
über sensible angelegenheit mehrfach
drängen auch chinesische staatsbürger
wie diese frau in malabo ein wirklich
sicher wären amerikas staatsgeheimnisse
hier also nicht tatsächlich fand das fbi
am montag unter anderem elf noch mit
geheimhaltungsstufen drei dokumenten
setzte streng geheim ein weiterer so
geheim dass nur ganz wenige personen den
inhalt kennen dürfen gestern hat die
justizminister garland die
veröffentlichung des
durchsuchungsbeschlusses beantragt und
dabei jeden vorwurf von politischen
motiven zurückgewiesen
die treue zur rechtsstaatlichkeit ist
das fundament des justizministeriums und
der demokratie das recht zu verteidigen
bedeutet es auf jeden gleichermaßen
anzuwenden furchtlos und ohne ansehen
der person
seit gestern sickerte aus
ermittlerkreisen wie sensibel die
gesuchten dokumente seien könnten
details über nuklearwaffen der usa oder
anderer staaten abhörprotokolle
informationen über den französischen
präsident die aufregung ist groß auch
wenn durchsuchungsbeschluss und
auflistung der beschlagnahmten 20
kartons wohl keine weiteren details
enthalten
es gab wohl informationen von einer
quelle dass dokumente in malaga
sensibelste fragen der nationalen
sicherheit betreffen die die vereinigten
staaten unbedingt schützen lassen ich
bin im streitkräfteausschuss und es gibt
nichts geheimes als material das mit dem
amerikanischen atomprogramm zu tun hat
all das bezeichnet donald trump als
politische hexenjagd nuklear dokumente
das stimme nicht in einem statement gab
er grünes licht für die veröffentlichung
des durchsuchungsbefehls
republikanische abgeordnete liefern ihm
heute schützenhilfe fordern antworten
für das amerikanische volk zu joe biden
missbrauch von justizministerium und fbi
als waffen gegen beiden politischen
gegner
dabei waren doch sensible
staatsgeheimnisse in malaga bis letzten
montag so gut wie ungeschützt
mrt wesen washington verfahren und
vorwürfe gegen pfand gibt es ja viele
wie gefährlich kann ihnen diese sache
werden
wir haben jetzt den
durchsuchungsbeschluss und demnach steht
er unter dem verdacht unter anderem der
spionage und das bedeutet das sei allein
die aufbewahrung solcher dokumente
unsachgemäße aufbewahrung mit zehn jahre
haft bestraft werden können wenn er sie
weiter gegeben hätte oder weitergeben
würde dann stünde darauf lebenslänglich
oder gar die todesstrafe nun sollte man
meinen das wäre dann rechtlich und
politisch gesehen das ende der karriere
von donald trump aber es gibt da eben
zwei probleme er kann versuchen die
verfahren herauszuzögern er hatte in
einem statement schon angekündigt dass
er der meinung ist er hat ja alles de
klassifiziert also sein wort als
präsident reicht aus um die
geheimhaltungsstufen aufzuheben das
stimmt natürlich nicht erreicht kein
abrakadabra dazu bedarf es eines
formalen prozesses aber er kann damit
verzögern und das zweite das politische
problem ist dass wir werden
wahrscheinlich die inhalte der einzelnen
momenten nie genau erfahren weil sie
eben streng geheim sind und das könnte
ihm helfen sondern an dazu erzählen dass
er alles ganz harmlos gewesen und er
käme damit davon leider sind auch
führende republikaner mit dabei dass sie
ihn entschuldigen gewissermaßen also am
ende könnte donald trump wieder einmal
ungeschoren davonkommen danke schon
immer nach washington
und dann kommen nach deutschland
und dass gesundheitsminister lauterbach
fasste die krone lage heute so zusammen
der deutliche rückgang der fallzahlen
gebe zwar erst einmal grund zur freude
sei aber noch kein grund für entwarnung
die todeszahlen sind ja auch nach wie
vor hoch
372 kroner tod in der vergangenen woche
in der woche davor waren es über 400 das
lka erwarteten den nächsten wochen
jedenfalls weiterhin eine hohe zahl an
krankenhauseinweisungen in den kliniken
ist die lage aber ich schon angespannt
und da kommt einiges zusammen mehr
corona patienten und zugleich
personalmangel und
personalausfälle durch infektionen vor
allem sind viele notaufnahmen am
anschlag und das nicht nur wegen corona
petra otto berichtet
sommerloch schön wär's hier in der
klinik am eichert in göppingen ist die
notaufnahme am anschlag und besonders in
der urlaubszeit wird sie zum
auffangbecken viele patienten kommen
hierher weil ihr hausarzt die praxis
geschlossen hat und
der vertreter niemand nehmen kann oder
der patient von sich aus sich hier
vorstellt indirekt in der notaufnahme
also aktuell in den letzten wochen und
23 monaten versorgen wir so viele
patienten wie nie zuvor mehr
patientinnen und patienten also und
gleichzeitig weniger mitarbeitende auch
weil gerade wieder besonders viele
ausfallen wegen krone sie hatten gehofft
die lage entspanne sich jetzt im sommer
das gegenteil ist der fall und
chefärztin katja mutter fällt es immer
schwerer ihre leute bei der stange zu
halten man spürt dass die mitarbeiter
auch die hoch motivierten mitarbeiter
mittlerweile am limit sind oder drüber
einige bleiben auch auf der strecke
geben auf
als ist persönlich nicht mehr schaffen
steigen der fachkräftemangel dauerthema
im gesundheitswesen und auch hier zu
spüren bei den rettungskräften in
stuttgart auch hier bis zu 20% corona
ausfälle und sie können gar nicht mehr
jede notaufnahme ansteuern
es ist so dass notaufnahmen teilweise
tatsächlich geschlossen sind temporär
geschlossen sind und das macht für uns
natürlich längere einsatzzeiten längere
bindungs zeiten für die fahrzeuge weil
wir dann eben nicht in die nächste
geeignete klinik fahren müssen sondern
eben in die übernächste die aufnahme
bereit überall in deutschland eine
ähnliche situation die notaufnahmen
unterbesetzt und überbelegt sie können
hier nicht einfach absagen oder
verschieben und sie fühlen sich manchmal
als letztes glied in der kette die
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter in den
notaufnahmen müssen und wollen ja
diejenigen die als notfall zu ihnen
kommen aufnehmen und im zweifelsfall
sind dann das auch mehr patientinnen und
patienten als die die man normalerweise
mit der personalbesetzung
bewältigen könnte das führt dann eben
auch zu wartezeiten in den notaufnahmen
und deswegen brauchen wir hier ordnung
und klare rahmenbedingungen und eine
bessere selbsteinschätzung der
patientinnen und patienten was sind
ernst in notfällen und was alltags
erkrankungen 70 prozent unserer
patienten werden nach der behandlung in
der notaufnahme wieder
entlassen und der größte teil davon
hätte auch an anderer stelle behandelt
werden können es ist täglich ein neuer
kampf gegen die überlastung gegen den
kollaps in der notaufnahme
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten hat
der schriftsteller salman rushdie ist
bei einem angriff im us-bundesstaat new
york schwer verletzt worden bei einer
veranstaltung stürmte ein mann auf die
bühne und stach auf den autor ein wegen
seines werks die satanischen verse hatte
irans oberster geistlicher vor mehr als
30 jahren zur tötung des autors
aufgefordert der 75-jährige rushdie
wurde mit einer verletzung am hals in
eine klinik geflogen
trotz umfangreicher untersuchungen und
hinweisen auf quecksilber im wasser ist
unklar was die ursache für das
massenhafte fischsterben in der oder ist
vom brandenburgischen umweltministerium
hieß es möglich sei auch eine
kombination mehrerer faktoren wie hitze
geringe wasserführung und giftstoffe
woher die möglichen giftstoffe kommen
könnten auch das ist noch unklar
der niedrige wasserstand der flüsse wird
zunehmend zum problem für die
schifffahrt frachtschiffe können nur
noch mit sehr wenig ladung fahren wie
hier in kaub am mittelrhein kauf gilt
als nadelöhr für die gesamte rhein
schifffahrt sollte der wasserstand
weiter fallen wächst die unsicherheit
wie lange frachtschiffe den rhein noch
nutzen können
gerhard schröder klagt gegen den
beschluss des bundestages der ihn seine
sonderrechte entzogen hatte der
haushaltsausschuss versagte dem
altkanzler unter anderem seien staatlich
finanziertes büro begründete den schritt
damit dass er keine offiziellen aufgaben
mehr wahrnehme der altkanzler steht
wegen seiner nähe zum russischen
präsidenten in der kritik
russland und die ukraine haben sich vor
dem un-sicherheitsrat
gegenseitig vorgeworfen für den beschuss
am atomkraftwerk sabrina verantwortlich
zu sein und damit eine nukleare
katastrophe zu riskieren seit tagen
kommt es immer wieder zu angriffen auf
das gelände das von russland
kontrollierten atomkraftwerks im süden
der ukraine die internationale
atomenergiebehörde verhandelt mit beiden
seiten der mit experten zugang zu der
anlage erhalten
seit bald zehn jahren ist die bundeswehr
mit un mandat in mali einer ihrer
gefährlichsten einsätze letztlich geht
es darum zu verhindern dass das land zu
einem aufmarschgebiet islamistische
terroristen wird doch mali zu
stabilisierung wie es im fachjargon
heißt ist kaum gelungen hinzu kommt dass
die generäle die sich dort letztes jahr
an die macht putschten nicht auf den
westen sondern auf russland setzen man
sehen hilfreich die russen für sie sein
werden die haben ja gerade eigentlich
anderswo schon ziemlich viel zu tun
die art jedenfalls wie sich marlies
machthaber verhalten wirft schon länger
die frage auf ob die bundeswehr da noch
bleiben soll heute hat berlin
beschlossen den einsatz vorerst
auszusetzen
das steckt aber auch ungute erinnerungen
berichtet david gepackt es hat sich
eingebrannt ins gedächtnis des landes
als schmach für die bundeswehr und ihre
verbündeten quasi aus dem land gejagt
vor einem jahr in afghanistan war
andreas eggert sieben mal im einsatz
jetzt fürchtet er dass sich geschichte
wiederholt in mali an dieser
überstürzten abzug der es auch immer
noch in den köpfen und die angst ist
einfach da dass es jetzt auch wieder
passieren könnte dass wir dort
menschen sehen sich da zweifel versuchen
das land zu verlassen und dazwischen
nimmt über 1000 soldaten soldaten der
bundeswehr auf noch ist es nicht soweit
doch die lage in mali spitzt sich zu
ihrer aufgabe aufklärung im rahmen der
un-mission minustah stellt die
bundeswehr nun erstmal ein das malische
militärregime hatte die deutsche
regierung wieder mal düpiert
überflugrechte verwehrt obwohl der
malische verteidigungsminister kamera
erst gestern genau das zugesichert hatte
amtskollegin lambrecht empört die taten
kameras sprechen eine andere sprache als
seine worte daher müssen wir maßnahmen
ergreifen und stellen die operation
unsere aufklärungskräfte und die
transportflüge mit der ch 53 bis auf
weiteres ein rund 140 soldaten aus
deutschland können nicht einreisen sie
sollten die abziehenden franzosen
ersetzen und den flughafen sichern doch
in mali scheinen viele längst auf andere
partner zu setzen putins russland
sollten eher der berüchtigten gruppe
wagner hatte die militär runter ins land
geholt erst diese woche lieferte
russland neue waffen und flugzeuge nach
mali wulff lessing der für die konrad
adenauer stiftung vor ort ist eine art
kalter stellvertreterkrieg russland
versucht über mali einen kleinen den
besten rein zu träumen den westen zu
starten man wollte den abzug der
franzosen provozieren das hat man
geschafft und jetzt ist halt deutschland
als größter truppensteller ins visier
geraten wenn wir jetzt auch noch
abziehen
die bundesregierung im dilemma das feld
anderen überlassen mit allen
konsequenzen oder an einem einsatz
festhalten der vor ort dermaßen
torpediert wird wenn die bevölkerung
oder sind sehr sehr viele menschen nicht
geschützt werden opfer von terror werden
dann werden sie sich auf den weg nach
europa machen und das ist unser
interesse dass dies nicht passiert
insofern muss man abwägen aber natürlich
gibt es grenzen die nicht überschritten
werden dürfen verlangt man es doch in
lambrecht hatte sich viel mehr um die
sache kümmern müssen sie hätte es zur
chefsache machen müssen dieses
vorläufige scheitern ist auch ihr
scheitern die lage in mali bleibt
angespannt bei der luftwaffe rüstet man
sich im zweifel schnell evakuieren zu
können bloß kein zweites afghanistan
in münchen werden ja gerade die european
championships ausgetragen in den
historischen wettkampfstätten der
olympischen spiele von
1972 die erinnerung an 72 ist natürlich
zwiespältige einerseits wurden die
spiele damals ja berühmt weil sie so
heiter gestaltet waren auch die athleten
schwärmten von der atmosphäre
bis zu jenem 5 september als daraus ein
albtraum wurde das attentat
palästinensischer terroristen auf die
israelische mannschaft und das
folgenschwere versagen der deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden
es war furchtbar
in jeder hinsicht
zum fünfzigsten jahrestag dieser
bitteren ereignisse ist eine große
gedenkveranstaltung geplant
angehörige der opfer haben allerdings
angekündigt die zeremonie zu
boykottieren berichtet sibylle bassler
50 jahre olympia attentat 50 jahre
quälen der schmerz und trauer für die
angehörigen der elf ermordeten sportler
einer von ihnen andré spitzer ein junger
familienvater die palästinensischen
terroristen führten ihn damals vor als
geisel schutzlos ausgeliefert bilder die
auch seine frau anke mit ansehen musste
die letzten vor seiner ermordung
was ist meinem mann dann zu gestoßen die
kam er ums leben ist er in einem
hubschrauber explodiert oder wurde
erschossen
fragen die lange unbeantwortet blieben
die deutschen behörden hielten
informationen zurück was bei der
geiselnahme und der missglückten
befreiungsaktion tatsächlich geschah ich
halte es für beschämend wie mit den
berechtigten anliegen der opfer in den
letzten 50 jahren umgegangen wurde das
verhalten der bundesregierung dass zu
dieser lage geführt hat ist leider sehr
sehr negativ ins ihre auswirkungen in
der vergangenheit waren 4,6 millionen
euro an die angehörigen gezahlt worden
weitere 54 millionen euro sollten nun
folgen
als klar wurde dass die deutsche seite
an kompensation anbietet geht mir das
für eine beleidigung
das kommt nicht annähernd in die höhe
dessen
internationalen standards entspricht wir
wären auch bereit das minimum zu
reduzieren aber nicht einfach ein
trinken trinken
deshalb haben die hinterbliebenen der
getöteten ihre teilnahme an der
gedenkfeier am 5 september in einem
brief an den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder
abgesagt 50 jahre schmähung lügen
erniedrigung und abweisung durch die
deutsche regierung und insbesondere
bayerische behörden sind mehr als genug
für uns nun versucht berlin zu retten
was zu retten ist und das leid der
angehörigen entsprechend zu würdigen
deswegen hat sich die bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit dem freistaat bayern und
der stadt münchen dazu entschieden
zusätzlich zu den bisher gezahlten
beträgen weitere anerkennungs leistungen
an die hinterbliebenen bereitzustellen
ob dies zu einer einigung führt noch
sind die gespräche im gange doch eines
steht fest das versagen verloren sind 72
hat sich noch über viele jahrzehnte
fortgesetzt und diese deutsche
bockigkeit und die schäbige mir halten
will für die hinterbliebenen der opfer
des anschlags ist eigentlich sogar noch
das größeres versagen in drei wochen
soll die gedenkfeier für die ermordeten
sportler stattfinden die zeit rinnt um
einen eklat in münchen abzuwenden
die folgen des ukrainisch krieges bzw
die folgen der deutschen abhängigkeit
von russischen gaslieferungen werden
spätestens im herbst weiterhin zu spüren
sein und mit dem thema geht es jetzt bei
dir weiter heißt habe
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck weitere
vorgaben zum energiesparen angekündigt
der süddeutschen zeitung sagt der havag
über das energie sicherungs gesetz
würden verordnungen erlassen unter
anderem sollen öffentlichen
liegenschaften nur noch auf 19 grad
geheizt werden krankenhäuser soziale
einrichtungen ausgenommen wir bleiben
ein stück wird beim thema
energieversorgung und schauen mit frank
bethmann auf die halbjahresbilanz zum
handel mit russland die kamen heute vom
statistischen bundesamt und zeigt das
liegt importe nach deutschland wertmäßig
deutlich gestiegen sind ja das mag auf
den ersten blick verwundern versuchen
wir uns doch seit monaten unabhängiger
vom russischen gas und öl zu machen rein
vom umfang ist uns das auch gelungen
doch die geringeren mengen an gelieferte
energie werden von den höheren preisen
deutlich überstiegen und so ist das
ergebnis ernüchternd mengenmäßig sanken
die importe aus russland im ersten
halbjahr um 24 prozent durch die höheren
preise aber stieg der wert dieser waren
um 51 prozent insgesamt summierten sich
die zahlungen auf 22,6 milliarden euro
mit anderen worten deutschland füllt die
russische kriegskasse weiter ordentlich
besonders interessant heimische
energieversorger haben sich zuletzt
weiter mit russischer kohle eingedeckt
noch bevor gestern ein import embargo
der eu gegriffen hat auffällig auch hier
die stark gestiegenen preise im märz
importierte deutschland rund 1,5
millionen tonnen kohle für 340 millionen
euro im juni waren es noch 1,3 millionen
tonnen für die man dann allerdings schon
450 millionen euro zahlen musste
russlands geschäfte also laufen noch die
einen sagen besser als erwartet die
anderen verweisen auf die schwächelnde
wirtschaftsleistung des landes zuletzt
ist das russische bruttoinlandsprodukt
um vier prozent eingebrochen
verantwortlich dafür die westlichen
sanktionen
frank bethmann vielen dank gerne zum
sport bei den schwimm
europameisterschaften in rom hat dieser
welt über 800 meter freistil die
silbermedaille gewonnen schneller war
nur die italienerin simona katharina und
bei den european championships in
münchen hat bmx freestylerin kim lea
müller silber gewonnen hinter
europameisterin evita miccoli kowar aus
tschechien ebenfalls silber für
triathleten laura lindemann über die
kurzdistanz europameisterin wurde die
britin on stanford und gold gab es auch
für deutsche sportlerinnen in münchen
bei der bahnrad em und zwar gleich
zweimal in der mannschaftsverfolgung
holten dieser brennauer franziska brause
mieke kröger und lisa klein im finale
gegen italien den titel und das gelang
im team-sprint auch immer hin zu pauline
grabosch und leer so viel friedrich im
finale und die niederlande
elf metern durchschnittlich elfmeter
haben sich im vergangenen jahr die
alpengletscher zurückgezogen bei manchen
etwa am großglockner in österreich sind
es sogar mehr als 40 meter die jetzt
fehlen an gletschern wandern gletschern
ganzjährig skifahren das so dass in
absehbarer zeit wohl nicht mehr geben
die berge das eh nicht vermissen wir
menschen aber den anblick
schneebedeckter gipfel ganz abgesehen
von den weitreichenden dramatischen
folgen dieser schmelze unser österreich
korrespondent wolf christian ullrich war
in den bergen man kann ziemlich
erschüttert zurück
seit gut 70 jahren ist ein bauer ernst
lasnik auf der glanz allen fest
verwurzelt er sieht und spürt genau wie
der klimawandel österreichs alpen
radikal verändert
seien in der letzten zeit sehr stark
geschwunden rollen die oberfläche man
sieht jetzt ja überall sehr zerklüftet
und kaum schnee wer in diesem jahr
österreichs berühmtesten gletscher
besucht zieht ein erschütterndes bild an
diesem punkt war vor 17 jahren noch das
eis erklärt uns bergführer martin
glanzstück wie dramatisch die gletscher
derzeit schmerzen zeigt sich an wenigen
orten so drastisch wie hier an der
pasterze am großglockner eine hitzewelle
löst die andere ab und dadurch schmilzt
dieses westliche schnee fällt aber den
pass der zum boden komplett weg und die
versorgung des gletschers systems wird
damit unterbrochen dieses jahr gab es
nur wenig neuschnee der ist längst
weggetaut und der sand von sahara strom
im frühling sorgt für braune stellen wo
das eis jetzt umso schneller schmilzt
diese veränderung ist nicht mehr
aufzuhalten die hier jetzt gerade
stattfindet gletscher kommen und gehen
über die jahrtausende mit eiszeiten und
wärme phasen was jetzt jedoch besonders
ist die enorm beschleunigte erwärmung
ausgelöst durch den klimawandel
hier am staaten klees war vor 150 jahren
noch eine riesige eiswand zeigt ranger
hermann week die zunehmende hitze
zerstört nicht nur die gletscher sondern
ist auch für tiere eine katastrophe das
birkwild schnee und zum beispiel wo es
muss in die hochlagen ausweichen und
ärger wenn die obergrenze erreicht ist
ist die gesagt wird der gesamte
artenreichtum steht irgendwo hinter
wohnt und wenn das eis schmitt droht mit
steinschlag und erdrutschen mehr gefahr
für den menschen am sonnblick
observatorium messen sie das tempo des
klimawandels was die menschheit global
verhindern will ist hier schon
wirklichkeit im jahresmitte ist es knapp
2 grad wärmer
die gletscher werden im alpenraum
verschwinden hier in österreich kann man
ja schon schlucken nur sagen wie wir
kinder wenn ihr jetzt die möglichkeit
habt guckt sich das lieber jetzt nochmal
an weil es ist tatsächlich dann leider
historisch das gesicht der alpen
verändert sich dramatisch es wird im
sommer ein braunes gebirge gefährlicher
für tier und mensch
das war es im original und damit geht es
an diesem freitagabend direkt weiter mit
dem neuen zdf politbarometer
die forschungsgruppe wahlen neben der
sonntagsfrage auch fragen zum ukraine
krieg und den hohen energiepreisen
bestellt ergebnisse jetzt von matthias
fonger
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer wir erleben einen
sonnigen trockenen sommer im krisenmodus
die pandemie der ukraine krieg dürre
brände das gas wird knapp die inflation
ist hoch in den letzten zehn jahren ging
es dann ruhiger zu eine mehrheit der
deutschen bewertete ihre eigene
wirtschaftslage dann auch lange als gut
anfang des jahres dann der einbruch auf
die zukunft blicken die befragten jetzt
eher skeptisch
knapp die hälfte glaubt ihre
wirtschaftslage wird in einem jahr
unverändert sein das sind deutlich
weniger als zu jahresbeginn
40 prozent erwarten dass ihre
finanzielle lage schlechter sein wird so
viele wie noch nie von einer
verbesserung gehen nur zehn prozent aus
zwar hat sich die inflation zuletzt
leicht abgeschwächt die preise aber sind
weiter hoch seines lebensmittel oder
sprit die bürger müssen tiefer in die
tasche greifen das zeugnis für die
bisherigen entlastungsmaßnahmen der
bundesregierung fällt denn auch eher
bescheiden aus nur fünf prozent finden
die bundesregierung tut zu viel zur
entlastung der bürger gerade richtig
findet die maßnahmen fast ein drittel 30
prozent
die meisten sagen aber die
bundesregierung entlastet zu wenig 58
prozent
mehrheitlich sehen dass die anhänger
aller parteien so besonders die dfg und
der linken
klar ist entlastungen in welcher form
auch immer müssen finanziert werden ob
der staat dazu neue schulden aufnehmen
oder die steuern erhöhen soll ein
einheitliches meinungsbild dazu gibt es
nicht jeder fünfte kann oder will sich
dazu überhaupt nicht äußern
anders bei der energieversorgung
russland liefert weniger gas die
situation ist weiter angespannt wie also
die versorgung sichern
geht es um den schnelleren ausbau
erneuerbarer energien sind die deutschen
sich so gut wie einig 93 prozent sind
dafür die zustimmung zu atomstrom
zumindest auf zeit wächst 65 prozent
wollen die noch aktiven atomkraftwerke
länger nutzen etwas weniger sind für
einen längeren betrieb der
kohlekraftwerke
61 prozent
dass deutschland unabhängig von
russischem gas und öl werden muss ist
eine konsequenz des krieges in der
ukraine
die folgen des krieges sind also auch
bei uns zu spüren
trotzdem ist eine deutliche mehrheit
dafür die ukraine weiter zu unterstützen
auch wenn das mit hohen energiepreisen
verbunden ist 71 prozent sehen das so 20
prozent nicht am geringsten ist die
zustimmung bei den anhängern der linken
und vor allem der afd
es ist ein turbulentes jahr bisher für
die ampel koalition die regierung steht
ständig unter zugzwang wenn nächsten
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme die spd
nur noch auf 19 prozent minus 2
cdu/csu davor unverändert 26 prozent die
grünen gleichauf ebenfalls 26 prozent
fdp 7 afd 12 alle plus 1 die linke
verliert leicht 4 prozent
wir kommen zu unserer top ten der
bewertungen der zehn wichtigsten
politikerinnen und politiker nach
sympathie und leistung auf der skala von
+5 bis -5
sahra wagenknecht ist schlusslicht minus
0,6 vorletzter friedrich merz minus 0,4
beide unverändert christian lindner
minus 0,2 etwas schwächer markus söder
unverändert minus 0,1 davor karl
lauterbach 0,3 über das heilen 0,7 beide
mit einbußen olaf scholz auf dem vierten
platz 0,8 unverändert jetzt vor ihm drei
grünen politiker cem özdemir gewinnt
dazu
1,02 annalena baerbock 1,3 und ganz vorn
weiter robert habeck 1,7 beide etwas
besser
zum schluss noch ein blick auf die
pandemie die sommer welle ist gebrochen
so der bundesgesundheitsminister heute
ein grund zur entwarnung ist das aber
nicht denn im herbst werden die
fallzahlen wohl wieder deutlich steigen
dann wäre eine mehrheit für strengere
maßnahmen
schulschließungen aber soll es nicht
geben 74 prozent finden es richtig dass
auszuschließen knapp ein viertel nicht
keine lockt downs mehr 68 prozent
stimmen zu 29 prozent nicht
die temperaturen lassen es noch nicht
vermuten aber der herbst rückt näher und
damit wird wohl auch der umgang mit
corona wieder ein größeres thema sein ob
es uns gefällt oder nicht
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in unserer zdf heute ab und oft zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste reguläre politbarometer gibt es
dann am 9 september hier folgt jetzt das
wetter und dann ein heute spezial mit
fabian köster und lutz van der horst zum
reizthema cannabis selbst test inklusive
einen schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend ja die aktuelle trockenheit zeigt
immer deutlicher ihre auswirkungen auf
die natur hier eingefärbt haben wir die
bodenfeuchte des bodens bis in 1 meter
80 tiefe das ist ein wichtiges maß um
den trockenstress von pflanzen und von
anbaukulturen abzuschätzen und wir sehen
in fast ganz deutschland herrscht eine
außergewöhnliche dürre das ist die
dunkelste einfärbung die rote einfärbung
zeigt immer noch eine extreme dürre an
eine ausgewogene bodenfeuchte ist
tatsächlich die ausnahme und gibt es nur
ganz im norden man sieht hier zum
beispiel auch den harz oder im südosten
und so wirklich mehr regen ist ja auch
nicht in sicht es ist heute nacht wieder
wolkenlos die schauer- und
gewitterwolken ganz im südosten die
fallen jetzt schnell in sich zusammen
denn wir haben uns im moment mit einer
recht trockenen luft masse zu tun und in
dieser kühlt es auch recht gut aus mit
teils nur acht grad südlich der donau 18
grad gibt es in küstennähe das speichert
das wasser küstennah hat das zu einem 20
21 grad noch die wärme und auch morgen
ist es dann wieder verbreitet heißt 34
grad am niederrhein 32 grad auch in
hamburg nur im südosten ist es mit 25
bis 29 grad etwas kühler denn hier hin
in den südosten und in den osten
transportiert morgen ein spürbarer
ostwind ein bisschen feuchtere und auch
schwüle luft da entwickeln sich dann
etwas mehr quellwolken darin einzelne
schauer und gewitter sind nachmittags
dabei sonst gibt es viel sonne ein
ähnliches wetter musste haben wir dann
auch am sonntag der montag wird
interessant haben wir einen
wetterumschwung mit wind aus südwesten
ein paar mehr wolken und regen und
gewittern sind dabei aber von der
regenmenge her kann dass die trockenheit
nicht lindern tschüss